Justice League.
We are facing an
existential threat to the planet!
Our only option is to destroy Darkseid!
Bow before me!
A global war means everyone on the planet is at risk.
You're gullible fools!
Darkseid is playing you.
The humans earned their fate.
I know you hate me but I wouldn't be
here if it wasn't necessary.
I'm completely on your side now.
No more planning.
Just do it!
We can't quit the Justice League doesn't
quit!
Henshaw may be gone.
But this was still the boldest move we've seen from Apokolips yet
Darkseid won't stay down
for long and we can't play defense
forever
then we agree we're going to have to
take this fight to his doorstep.
Excellent!
Count me in...
Team!
Okay, who left the front door open?!
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my Justice League dark
Apokolips war Trailer there's a bunch
of Easter eggs and I actually think that
they're borrowing from some of the
deleted Justice League sequels the
live-action Justice League sequels when
it used to be a trilogy some of this may
actually seem familiar if you know about
a lot of the deleted scenes from the
original Justice League movies so I'll
explain as we go along if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Easter egg videos we're doing a
movie ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video I know you're asking why is the
title so complicated why didn't they
just call it Justice League dark side
war that'd be a badass title for a movie
I think the reason why they call it
Justice League dark Apokolips war is
just to let you know that it's a Justice
League Justice League dark crossover
movie because of all the Constantine
stuff and he's a big main character
during the film so if you're a big fan
of that character it sounds like he's
going to be huge during this next Darkseid
war style story as you see from the
pitch you basically have some of the
Justice League turning evil it sounds
like that's an anti-life equation in
dark side just emcees a bunch of the
Justice League characters particularly
Batman like you see him apologizing to
Damian Wayne I know I'm the last person
you want to trust and of course Damian
Wayne justice asses him through the
entire trailer and here's the crazy
thing if you guys didn't see the slate
of the title at the end of the movie
with the date and all that stuff it's
actually a rated R movie that's right a
Justice League rated R movie if you ever
thought that that would happen my guess
is is they just go super hardcore with
it that's the only reason why these
animated movies wind up being rated R
they did Batman Killing Joke
as a rated R movie but that's obviously
a very very hardcore comic book story so
when you heard that they were doing
Killing Joke it was easier to understand
why they might make it rated R but
hearing they just a regular typical
bigger Justice League movie is rated R
as a bit of a surprise nowadays because
the Joker movie blew up so big made over
a billion dollars in the DC black label
seems like it's going to be a thing in
the live-action universe now DC rated R
movies don't seem so weird digging
deeper into the Easter eggs and deleted
scenes from the other Justice League
movie it sounds like the pitch is
similar to the plot of the cancelled
Justice League sequel when Justice
League was still planned as a trilogy of
movies and I'm talking about
live-action Justice League after all
that stuff happened they came out and
they explained what the other two movies
were supposed to be in that plan trilogy
so the second movie was going to be there
Empire Strikes Back with kind of a
downer ending with Darkseid coming to
earth at the beginning of the movie
destroying everything enslaving Superman
using the anti-life equation after he
killed Lois Lane just to keep Superman
on Team Darkseid that was all supposed
to play in to the batman vs superman
nightmare sequence that was supposed to
be a vision of the future that came to
pass in the second Justice League movie
all that second movie Darkseid war stuff
Superman anti-life equation was supposed
to set up the concept of the flash
time-travel scene in Batman vs Superman
during Justice League 3 so in that third
movie the flash was going to go back in
time with cyborgs help and Batman to
warn Batman in the past to save Lois
Lane obviously we never saw any that
come to pass there was this other plot
line where they had tried it before they
were stuck in this time loop in the
first time that they tried to go back
into the past it didn't work which is
why all this terrible stuff happened
during Justice League 2 so when we get
to Justice League 3 they try the other
point in time to go back to that winds
up being successful Batman saves Lois
Lane from Darkseid Superman never
succumbs to the anti-life equation and
they're able to form the full Justice
League with the help of Hal Jordan in
the full Green Lantern Corps who would
have shown up earlier in the trilogy
most of that stuff never got filmed that
was just the story that they wrote that
they would have started shooting back in
2017 2018 after that first Justice
League movie came out Kevin Smith did
this whole long story about how he saw a
bunch of Jim Lee's concept art that's
right Jim Lee who's now like the sole
publisher of DC because of all the stuff
going on behind the scenes at DC Comics
did all this stuff for the Justice
League trilogy when it was still
supposed to be a trilogy while they were
making that first Justice League movie
the studio canceled the trilogy plans
turned it into one movie which is the
one we saw in theaters so it sounds like
the DC animated people love some of
those story concepts and decided to pick
up on that and do their own version of
it as a rated R movie like okay we'll do
this Darkseid coming to earth taking
over everything all hope is lost some of
the Justice League get emceed by the
anti-life equation then a bunch of the
villains have to work with the heroes
and come
cause to save the earth and get rid of
dark side like the reign of the Superman
post-credit scene so if you haven't
watched DC animated movies in a while
there's sort of a Justice League line of
continuity with the Superman films in
the last couple of years some of the DC
animated films are sort of one-off and
they stand on their own but some of them
are connected and that includes the
death of Superman
reign of the Superman and now this
sequel Justice League dark Apokolips
war there was a reign of the Superman
post-credit scene where Lex Luthor just
comes on to the Justice League's
satellite and says hey team what's going
on we ready to defeat Darkseid we know
he's coming obviously they're pissed
about it because this is just happening
now and he's been their villain for a
long time but a while ago in the comics
they did a story line called Justice
League dark side war and during that Lex
Luthor also does work with the Justice
League to try and save everyone they
take it in a bunch of really twisty ways
trying to use the Lex Luthor characters
in a way that you haven't seen him
before they blame him a little bit more
like an antihero a little more
complicated but he still really does not
like Superman one of the great Easter
eggs you kind of noticed in the
background here too though is the Lex
Luthor does not do things out of the
goodness of his heart he's obviously
using this as an opportunity to turn
public opinion in his favor he usually
uses situations like this particularly
when Justice League characters go ham on
everyone else and they turn against each
other so that later when the disaster is
over and they win the day he can go to
the public looking like a hero see I
worked with the Justice League to get
rid of Darkseid I'm so amazing now I'm
such a hero elect me to public office
then he can pull a very Spider Man far
from home post credits scene style twist
where he shows everyone footage of
Justice League characters doing evil
things under the control of Darkseid
although he doesn't tell them about
Darkseid controlling them with the
anti-life equation you do imagine a DC
version of J jonah Jameson just
shaking his fist complaining about
Justice League characters trying to turn
public opinion against them that's a
very classic Lex Luthor style twist to
pull and if you're big Justice League
dark fan there's obviously a lot of
Justice League dark stuff going on
during this with Constantine going up
against Darkseid trying to use his magic
against him I really like this scene
here where it seems like he's trying to
read Flash's mind and seems like he sees
a vision of flashpoint like oh wow some
stuff is happy
we don't know what's going on the
universe has already been rebooted once
but if you're big fan of Justice League
dark it actually sounds like JJ Abrams
bad robot operation is going to be
working on some kind of Justice League
dark movie but I don't know who would
direct that who they would cast in it if
they would use Matt Ryan as their
live-action version of Constantine it
would be really cool if they did that
crisis on Infinite Earths on the DC TV
shows kind of tried to bring all of that
stuff together with the movie stuff
because of the big Ezra Miller flash
crossover with TV flash probably one of
the best moments from crisis on Infinite
Earths but when it comes to the
live-action movies I wouldn't hold your
breath too much about a lot of the TV
characters appearing in the live-action
movies and speaking of Darkseid Tom King
said that they're almost done writing
the New Gods movie I believe they're a
couple drafts in they've been working on
it for a while now the movie is based on
his mr. miracle run which is amazing if
you haven't read that and you're really
big fan of the comics do check it out
Tom King has been doing some fantastic
stuff in related to Jack Kirby stuff but
we're talking about New Gods Darkseid
stuff Jack Kirby over at Marvel the very
first Marvel Eternals trailer is
probably going to drop in the next month or
two so of course I'll do videos for that
movie when we get it we find out what
it's actually going to look like but
everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about them doing a
rated-r Justice League animated movie it
just blows my mind that they would even
try that the internet went a little
crazy this past week because of Henry
Cavill Wolverine stuff here's the video
the explaining what was going on with that
what the reality is and click here
for that brand new spider-man 3 announcement
Thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome.
I'll see you guys tonight!